Let's discuss the security of DES.
First, we observe that the actual
key value is only 56 bits.
That means there are only a total
of 2 to the 56 possible keys.
This key space is too small, because
an attacker can use brute force to
find the correct key relatively,
easily using today's computers.
Another issue with DES is
that the design criteria for
the S-boxes have been kept secret.
On one hand, they have been shown to
be resistant to attacks that were
published years after DES was published.
This means that DES is quite secure.
On the other hand, because the design
criteria have been kept a secret,
one have to wonder what are the designer
of this actually knew about
these attacks years before
they were published.
One could argue that these design
criteria should have been published, so
the researchers can review them and
improve upon them.